Trascrizione: Eleonora Salis
Revisore: marshall8 mathers88
Vi siete mai chiesti quali siano le regole
del gioco
che il pianeta ha sempre condiviso
con tutti gli organismi
viventi che lo abitano?
Vi chiedo di concentrarvi su tre parole.
Adattarsi.
Spostarsi.
Estinguersi.
E sono qui oggi per condividere con voi
l'importanza di queste tre parole con
degli esempi.
La prima regola, la prima opportunità,
forse meglio dire
che il pianeta ci ha sempre dato
a disposizione
è quella di adattarsi.
E dopo averci pensato a lungo, non ho
trovato nessun esempio migliore
di un animale curioso che secondo
me conoscete tutti.
Il mammut.
Come il mammut.
In un mondo completamente all'opposto di
quello che conosciamo oggi, dove il
freddo, il gelo e le basse temperature
avanzano, tutti gli organismi viventi nel
cuore dell’era glaciale sono chiamati a
reagire, a fare qualcosa per sopravvivere.
E nessuno lo fa meglio del Mammut,
un gigantesco animale
cinque metri al garrese.
Queste zanne enormi, popolazioni di
branchi immensi che si spostano lungo
tutti i continenti dell'emisfero
settentrionale.
Nessuno riesce a vincere la sfida
dell’adattamento all’era glaciale,
come il mammut.
Poi le cose cambiano, il clima si
trasforma un’altra volta
e il mammut si estingue
circa 12.000 anni fa.
O così pensavamo?
Perché ci siamo sbagliati
Abbiamo davvero sottovalutato che
cosa può voler dire adattarsi.
Qualche anno fa dei colleghi paleontologi
scoprono dei resti di mammut su quella
che è oggi una remota isola nel Mar
Glaciale Artico, a nord della Siberia.
La vera sorpresa, però , ci arriva quando
queste ossa ci restituiscono un’età.
4000 anni.
Che cosa vuol dire? Che questi animali,
questi mammut, erano ancora vivi e vegeti
nello stesso momento in cui
gli  antichi egizi,
in quella che oggi è la piana di Giza,
studiavano più o meno come disporre
le prime pietre su cui avrebbero
costruito le piramidi.
E allora la prospettiva
cambia completamente.
Questi animali avevano trovato un modo di
adattarsi e di diventare sostenibili
con quella piccola isoletta così
efficiente da salvarli.
Erano diventati più piccoli, avevano
ridotto la loro popolazione e soprattutto
erano diventati sostenibili con quello che
avevano a disposizione
e in questo modo avevano fatto qualcosa di
incredibile Avevano ingannato
l'estinzione della loro specie.
E in realtà anche noi per oltre 8000 anni.
La seconda regola o la seconda opportunità
è quella di spostarsi.
E nessuno meglio di Homo sapiens può
essere il testimonial di questa storia.
Circa 120.000 anni fa, Homo sapiens muove
letteralmente i primi passi in quella che
oggi è l’Africa orientale e all’inizio,
per star bene nonostante
le difficoltà di questa regione, ha tutto
ciò di cui ha bisogno.
Poi però la popolazione cresce e
nell'unica ottica di stare bene,
sopravvivere, avere delle opportunità
migliori, decide di fare questo tentativo
di giocare questa carta, cioè spostarsi
e nessuno mai lo farà così bene
in un tempo velocissimo
arriviamo dappertutto dall’Africa, in
Europa, in Asia, nelle Americhe
fino in Oceania.
Siamo inarrestabili da questo
punto di vista.
Ma perché continuiamo a trovare
opportunità una dopo l'altra?
Il meccanismo però si inceppa quando i
nostri antenati cominciano a fare qualche
cosa di diverso, ovvero ad andare avanti,
lasciando però terra bruciata dietro.
Questo li costringe a fare una cosa
diversa. Non possono più tornare indietro,
possono solo andare avanti.
Avanti, avanti, sempre avanti.
Ma in un pianeta che, lo sappiamo, è
finito e limitato. Ha dei confini.
Altro problema è che nel lasciare
terra bruciata dietro di noi.
Togliamo questa carta a tutti gli altri.
Non siamo gli unici su questa mappa, ci
sono altre specie.
E a loro togliamo quel
salvagente, quella carta vincente che per
noi letteralmente ha fatto la differenza
tra la vita e la morte.
La terza regola, ahimè
fa rima in
realtà con quello
che è l’amore della mia vita,
ciò a cui ho destinato tutte le
mie energie negli ultimi venti anni,
la mia più grande passione.
Perché nulla e sarete d'accordo con me,
fa rima con estinzione.
Meglio di dinosauro.
I dinosauri sono stati i dominatori del
nostro pianeta proprio sfruttando
le opportunità che
il pianeta ha dato loro,
incluso adattarsi, incluso spostarsi.
E in questo modo sono sopravvissuti per
un periodo di tempo che oggi ci sembra
quasi impossibile anche solo da capire.
180 milioni di anni
Ci mette un po’ in
prospettiva questo.
E le cose sono cambiate quando
i cambiamenti che hanno dovuto
affrontare semplicemente si sono
rivelati troppi.
Un giorno nefasto.
Un asteroide o un meteorite impatta sul
pianeta Terra e non lascia alternative.
Non c'è tempo per modificarsi,
non c'è tempo per spostarsi.
Solo pochissimi ci riescono
ed alcuni lo fanno.
Per i dinosauri, invece, vuol dire
obbedire alla terza regola estinguersi.
Perché se c'è una vera costante del
pianeta per i dinosauri, per i mammut,
per noi è proprio il cambiamento.
Il punto però è accorgersi
di qual è
la velocità di questo cambiamento.
È quello che fa tutta la differenza,
sempre.
Io di mestiere faccio il paleontologo.
Dinosauri a parte, ovvero studio tutti gli
organismi viventi che sono stati qui
sul nostro pianeta prima di noi nel tempo.
E mi sono accorto che le infinite
possibilità di sopravvivenza,
le infinite idee,
sono assolutamente incredibili.
Ma mi sono anche accorto che ogni volta
in cui il pianeta ha messo in scena
ha fatto partire un cambiamento,
ci sono sempre stati dei segnali
molto molto chiari.
È un po come il mondo che vediamo oggi,
abbiamo migliaia di segnali diversi,
abbiamo la CO2 che aumenta, il livello dei
mari che sale
la biodiversità che cambia, il clima.
Abbiamo le popolazioni che si spostano
perché hanno lasciato terra bruciata
e non hanno altro su cui contare.
Ci sono sempre stati questi segnali,
questi messaggi molto chiari.
L’importante è non cumularli e non
arrivare al terremoto,
non arrivare al punto di rottura
perché altrimenti le
alternative diventano davvero poche.
Quello che mi ha sempre dato da riflettere
riguarda proprio la nostra
specie, perché è come se ci fossimo
convinti di essere gli unici a giocare
su questo pianeta.
In realtà le regole sono
un pochino diverse.
Vediamo se riuscite a fare con me,
a immaginare nella vostra testa
un esempio un po’ strano: una partita
a poker.
Immaginatevi un gruppo di amici che
si trova per una partita a poker.
Si conoscono davvero da tanto tempo.
Loro hanno fatto partire il gioco e le
sue regole
e semplicemente hanno
il piacere di stare insieme,
di fare questa partita.
Sono in grado di accettare che le regole
del gioco includono vincere e perdere,
ma l’importante è trovarsi e
continuare a giocare.
Una sera arriva un nuovo ospite che si
siede a questo tavolo e inizia a giocare.
Entusiasta, curioso, apprende le regole
e gioca secondo le regole degli altri.
Poi, dopo un po’, giocando una mano dopo
l’altra, inizia, come è normale che sia,
a perderne qualcuna, ma non è in
grado di accettare questa cosa.
E per la prima volta a quel tavolo da
gioco un giocatore decide di barare.
Non è in grado di accettare di poter
perdere una mano, ma di continuare
a essere lì con gli altri giocatori.
Ora vi chiedo se voi foste uno dei
fondatori di questo gioco, se voi foste
uno dei quattro grandi protagonisti di
questa immagine, cosa fareste
nei confronti del baro?
Di quello che invece di accettare le
regole del gioco, vuole farlo saltare
il tavolo da gioco?
Non so voi, ma probabilmente
lo fareste andare via.
Lo accompagnereste a un altro
tavolo da gioco.
Al pianeta.
A quelli che giocano non importa tanto
di noi. Non siamo fondamentali
è esattamente l’opposto.
Noi abbiamo il privilegio di essere
seduti a questo tavolo da gioco.
Ora, al di là della retorica, al di là di
tutto, io credo davvero che ci siamo
seduti a un tavolo da gioco in cui
c'era una partita in corso.
Abbiamo avuto la brillante idea di cercare
di cambiare le carte in tavola,
le regole in corso d'opera.
Non possiamo pretendere che gli altri
giocatori siano felici, ma di nuovo
abbiamo la possibilità di capire che cosa
stiamo facendo e soprattutto abbiamo
un manuale di istruzioni.
Basta leggerlo, basta agire di conseguenza
altrimenti gli altri
giocatori probabilmente si
stancheranno di noi.
Noi viviamo in un periodo in cui siamo
giustamente proiettati sul futuro.
Siamo davvero preoccupati per quello che
succederà domani e per fortuna cominciamo
a ragionarci utilizzando il cervello e le
regole che ci sono state poste davanti.
Ma proprio in questo momento di fretta, in
questo momento in cui tutto ci sembra
urgente, c’è una frase che secondo me
è davvero importante e che per me
ha significato davvero tanto, soprattutto
per mettere tutto nella giusta
prospettiva, inclusi noi, inclusa
la nostra specie.
Perché dovremmo guardare al passato
per essere pronti, per essere preparati
al nostro futuro?
Molto semplicemente, perché non c'è alcun
altro luogo dove andare a guardare.